嗯，我想你可以大致把它归到移民、或者非法移民之类的范畴里。
我会说是大规模移民。
大规模移民。人口结构在一种文化、一个社会、一个民族的形成中所扮演的角色——你为此受到了不少批评，也引发了很多争议。你对那些争议有后悔吗？
你总体上是怎么想的？
一刻都没有。好。我这么说的原因是，舆论的窗口不会自己打开。它是一次一次地被人推动着打开的，靠的是有人愿意冒一点名声上的风险、承受一点回击、一点批评，或者也许
有时候是很大的名声代价、很多批评、很多回击。我认为欧洲的大规模移民问题在很多年里都是一个彻底的禁忌，在好几个欧洲国家至今仍是如此。可能是因为机缘巧合，也可能是因为别的原因，
反正丹麦不在其列。丹麦人从上世纪90年代中期就开始讨论大规模移民及其后果了，
非常早。其中一部分可以追溯到一个人，一个非常古怪的人物。我记得80年代在电视上看到他谈论大规模移民的危险，那还是在80年代，我长大的时候，
我长大的那个街区，在Bonto，那是84年还是哪年，99%都是丹麦族裔，都是能把血统追溯到在这片土地上生活了一千年的丹麦人。丹麦拥有世界上最古老的君主制之一，
一直可以追溯到哈拉尔·蓝牙王——蓝牙标准就是以他命名的。所以一千多年了，有很长的世系，有些人一直住在同一个地方，那个街区里99%的人都是如此，然后
到了90年代初，我想大概变成了5%左右，而到现在已经降到了60%多或者70%。
嗯。那是很大的变化。丹麦人开始注意到、开始谈论这件事，意识到这并非全然的福音，大规模移民是有代价的。大约在90年代，这场辩论真正席卷了整个2000年代，
而邻国却没有发生这样的情况。尤其是瑞典，完全没有这场辩论。彻底的禁忌。挪威也一样。欧洲其他一些国家也一样。而突然间，到了15年之后，我们经历了
一百万叙利亚人的大迁徙，他们沿着欧洲的高速公路步行而来，德国选择接收了其中很多人，有三万人抵达了丹麦等等。嗯，这件事受到了更多关注，对吧？因为这种
变化确实发生了。我发现，判断一种文化里哪里出了问题的一个方法，就是看你能谈论什么？准确地说，是你能注意到什么。
我在一篇文章里注意到的——那是多久以前？才一年半前吧。我记得是写伦敦，我大概在90年代末开始来伦敦，那时无论如何，是59%、60%的英国族裔，
而20年后，降到了34%左右。这是很明显的。真的，就走在街上，你会意识到，嗯，这跟我20年前来的时候已经不是同一个城市了。而如果你
再往前推20年，你会回到跟丹麦人差不多的比例。在85年、90年代，这还是一个英国族裔占85%、90%的国家。再往前推，那又是另一个国家了。一代人的时间里就变了。注意到这一点是没问题的。
觉得“你知道吗？我不认同这样，我希望不是这样”，也是没问题的。我是说，我上次去中国是2019年，在上海。嗯，那里全是中国人。如果我今年十月再去，突然发现
只有30%是中国人，70%是其他人，我会觉得有点奇怪。我大概会说：“呃，发生什么了？”
嗯，如果当时中国人说“我们不喜欢这样”，我也不会觉得被冒犯。所以那种认为欧洲国家没有权利注意到正在发生的事、没有权利反对正在发生的事的想法，我觉得就是
错的。对吧？我认为自决在道德上是有依据的，而且我们在世界其他地区一直在援引这个论据——那里的人民对他们所在的地区、他们的国家拥有自决权。
嗯，对国家拥有自决权。我认为，比如说丹麦人、瑞典人或挪威人说“我们在这里作为王国存在了一千年，有着某种特定的族群构成”，这完全合理。我是说，我是
移民的坚定支持者。我自己就是美国的移民。嗯，精挑细选的移民——各国竞相吸引全世界最聪明、最有才华的人——那真的很好。
非法的择优移民。
这里的关键是“择优”，因为实际上大多数欧洲国家几乎没有非法移民。南欧有一些非法移民，但大多数欧洲国家并没有严重的非法移民问题。而
问题在于其他类型的大规模移民，最终导致人口结构与几十年前甚至短短几十年前完全不同。我认为欧洲国家会从移民中受益。事实上，
关于丹麦人有趣的一点是，他们对移民有非常详细的统计数据。我不太确定为什么他们统计得这么细。也许可以追溯到蒙格利斯特罗普和他90年代的讨论，但他们确实这么做。而从
这些统计数据中可以清楚地看到，当来自英国、法国、美国的人来到丹麦时，平均而言，这些移民对丹麦国家非常有益。他们的贡献远远超过他们对国家的索取。所以
丹麦应该接受那些贡献远大于索取的移民。然后你看看其他类型的移民群体。上周刚出来一份统计，是一位丹麦政客要求
我想是财政大臣用最新数据做的这份统计。让那些正面移民来到丹麦，国家要付出什么成本？我刚才提到的那些案例，名单上的法国、英国、美国，他们
都集中在同一个数字附近，大约每年给丹麦国家带来25000美元的净收益。我当时想，哇，这非常正面，这又是平均值，对吧。然后光谱的另一端，成本最高的移民是索马里人，他们
平均每年给丹麦国家造成28000美元的成本。我觉得丹麦人这么说很合理：我们更愿意多来些法国人、英国人和美国人，而不是那么多索马里人。
你觉得为什么那条帖子招来那么多恨？
在很多圈子里，那是一个非常忌讳的话题。
部分原因跟奥弗顿窗口的扩大有关，
我确信如此。但我也认为——我想在这里做最强的论证。我确实认为这可能会变得丑陋，对吧？这些事情有没有可能滑向赤裸裸的种族主义，其根基不是别的，
而只是对他人的仇恨？是的，那可能发生。但这种风险并不能否定讨论的必要性——讨论你国家的人口构成以及你的移民政策应该是什么样的。我还觉得特别好笑的是，
尤其是在欧洲，这种短视——关于欧洲人是否有权自主决定自己国家面貌的讨论，那套标准似乎只适用于那里。没人会去
告诉日本人：“嘿，你们太日本了。”比如东京大概98%是日本族裔，对吧？有人会去告诉日本人，说如果东京的日本族裔比例降到
伦敦那种水平，比如37%，东京会变成一个更好的国家吗？我不这么认为。所以在我看来，这里有一种奇怪的、几乎自我厌恶的东西。我是说，上帝称之为‘自杀式共情’，它渗透在这一切之中，程度之深
我至今还没完全想明白。比如，这是从哪来的？为什么会这样？但无论如何，我只是注意到，嘿，伦敦看起来不一样了。我更偏爱以前的伦敦，就像我会说我更偏爱
我在哥本哈根长大的那个街区80年代的样子。我完全理解你怎么会一下子跳五步说，好吧，那是种族主义。我也不在乎了。这就是一个应该进行的公平讨论。国家和人民有权
制定移民政策，而那种我们不应该有任何边界、或者更糟——一切都是白板、所有民族都一样、我们可以把人从地球的一个地方搬到
地球的另一个地方，一切都会顺顺利利——这种观念，从经验上看是不成立的。欧洲从80年代起就一直在做这个实验。结果并不好。现在欧洲有一些力量想要
推翻这个实验，想要结束迄今为止所实行的大规模移民。我恰好相信，大多数丹麦人和许多其他人也相信，你知道嘛，是的，我们一直以来的做法行不通。
我们得做出一些改变。我不认为这意味着零移民。再说一次，我自己就是移民。我认为美国总体上从移民中受益匪浅。但那是一种障眼法。移民的好坏很大程度上取决于
是谁在移民。当一个国家接收的移民是对社会的净贡献者时，国家就会受益。而且在大多数情况下，他们会融入当地文化。如果你来到丹麦，想成为一个丹麦人，你付出了所有
努力，你对社会有贡献，我想大多数丹麦人会非常乐意允许这样的人进来，数量合理就行。如果你来到丹麦，不想融入，你是社会的净负担，你活在一个平行社会里，那也同样
丹麦人说“咱们别这么干了”很合理。有意思的是，我对美国移民制度不太熟，但据我所知，婚姻为基础的移民制度在这儿还没通过。
而且美国文化也非常不同。这一点我直到在两个地方都长期生活过才真正体会到。美国有一种“可选同化”的文化，也就是说，从丹麦、乌克兰或任何地方来的人，接受美国那套价值观、规范和文化，然后就能被其他美国人当作自己人尊重，这要容易得多，也宽容得多。
所以从丹麦、乌克兰或随便哪儿来美国的人，只要认同美国的价值观、规范和文化，就能被其他美国人尊重为美国人。
[吸气声]
所以每次有人说“美国是个种族主义国家”，我就觉得特别好笑。我就想：你去过别的地方吗？你知道别的国家什么样吗？如果你觉得美国是最种族主义的国家，那你就是信息太闭塞了。
是啊。
我是说，我们在丹麦生活的那段时间就深有体会。我妻子是美国人，有斯堪的纳维亚血统，
但在美国已经好几代了。非常难。
作为一个金发碧眼的女人，
她付出了各种努力，
学语言、做一切能做的事，但还是要非常非常难才能融入丹麦文化。而如果反过来，她是丹麦人搬到美国，
根本就不会那么难。这也是另一件事——生活在丹麦这样的国家，带着一个有着斯堪的纳维亚血统、已经付出全部努力的美国妻子，我仍然意识到：
老天，同化真是太难了，哪怕你已经做到了97%的程度。那如果你来自一个完全陌生的文化和规范，那几乎就是不可能了。当然，这正是
我刚才引用的那些数据所证明的：文化差异越大、距离越远，成功融入的可能性就越低。
表达这种立场有没有让你失去友谊或关系？有，但不仅仅是这个。我觉得更多是2020年前后出现的那道巨大分界线，很多政治断层线就是从那时真正
裂开的。在美国，简单来说就是：你“觉醒”了没有？显然，我有一批我以为关系很好、认识很多年的人，一旦那条政治断层线出现，他们明显
就不再是朋友了。我觉得这很遗憾。我也试着努力去理解这是怎么来的，部分原因是我这些年也在好几个议题上改变过想法。就像——
有时候你就是过了一段时间想法变了。有时候你得到新信息后想法变了。改变想法的原因和时机有很多。而且我们不会都在同一个时间表上改变，甚至有人根本不会变。
所以让自己身边有——或者至少去接触——那些不是每个话题都跟你想法一样的人，我觉得这很健康。比如我偶尔跟我兄弟讨论政治。我们并不是在所有
这些话题上都看法一致，有时讨论还会有点激烈，但之后也会冷静下来，然后我们都意识到：好吧，我们在这个问题上不一致，但在很多其他事情上是一致的。我们欣赏很多
同样的东西。其实这也是我们在 Basecamp 大吵一架之后，我以全新方式体会到的一件事：早先那条规范——不要跟陌生人、甚至熟人，尤其是同事，谈政治、宗教或钱——
这真的不是个好主意。如果你不总是把政治分歧拿出来互相摩擦，你就更有可能跟别人保持良好的工作关系。所以我其实认为自由派
和保守派应该合作。我觉得如果各个阵营完全割裂、彼此之间没有任何重叠或互动，这个国家会糟糕得多。而如果你不总是盯着分歧，
这种交融就会容易得多。多关注你们共同喜欢的东西。我是说，我在科技圈里就有一些不幸渐行渐远的人。我们曾经有那么多共同点，比如都热爱 Ruby
或其他东西。这不是很可惜吗？我希望生活在一个分歧也很有趣、也值得聊的世界里。
是的。
而且不要过于情绪化。
对。
即使是激进的分歧也要这样，因为首先，分歧之中才有意思的东西。
是的。
而且，这也是你成长的方式。如果分歧被接纳，并被带入一个大家可以讨论的共同体中，这就是社会健康的标志。
对我来说，一个很好的例证是，我看过一段威廉·F·巴克利的节目片段，我记得叫《开火线》还是
类似的名字。
他请了一位黑豹党成员
参加他的讨论小组。
很明显，这两位先生的政治立场几乎没有共同点。他们却能交谈下去——我记得我看了25分钟——巴克利就只是问，那你怎么看这个？你怎么看
这个？而那位黑豹党成员就像你预期70年代的黑豹党人会回答的那样回应。里面并没有多少安抚性的语气。我当时就想，哇，这太罕见了。如果你看过
放到今天，那场面肯定变成一场互相叫骂。只会是双方来回抛掷指责。巴克利能跟那些他强烈反对的人进行这样的对话，同时还能
深入探讨他们立场中所有智识层面的东西，让他们把这些面向讲清楚——这属于一个已经逝去的时代，我非常想回到那样的时代。我的意思是，其实我一直很喜欢跟信得过的朋友聊政治，因为可以聊
这些话题，而不至于把它变成生死攸关的大事。但如今这个时代，有某种东西让这种对话越来越难得。所以你刚才说出的那些话很重要，需要经常讲，提醒人们记住一个
我们都该努力追求的理念：能够存在分歧，并且能聊、能讨论这些分歧，因为政治其实挺有意思的。我已经习惯说“我讨厌政治”了。但我真正想说的是，眼下这套
运作方式——某些话题，我太清楚了，你知道所有那些一说出口就能把你归到蓝队或红队的话术，然后制造出的是戏剧冲突，而不是对话。我能想到
很多无害的话——如果我不盯着互联网的话。我能想到一大堆无害的、分析世界局势的表述，结果会触发所有人说：“哦，那家伙是个左派废物，或者
你知道，右翼法西斯。”然后客观来说，如果我不盯着互联网，我会——而且我确实曾经——感到震惊，因为我没有深入关注互联网。嗯，但比如说读很多东西、
为乌克兰战争做很多准备的时候，我震惊地发现，我某些表述会被理解成某种立场，然后遭到猛烈攻击。但那种攻击在做的事情是，它在说：“嘿，你
这个以为自己可以自由行动、自由思考的人，选一个筐，坐进去。穿上那件蓝衬衫或红衬衫，然后——然后我实际意识到的是，事情会平息下来。它们不会——系统不会找你麻烦，
只要你直接说‘我是蓝队的人’或者‘我是红队的人’。
对吧？
但如果你只是好奇地探索这个世界、对世界进行理性思考，系统就会惩罚你。我、我、我讨厌这一点，因为我想回到巴克利和黑豹党那种对话。
是的。而且你只是在表达观点，但务实地看这个局面，我意识到：除非我真的在意某个议题，否则不要提政治，因为我意识到那是有代价的。他们会把你塞进蓝筐或红筐里。
所以，你在选择发声时得更慎重。
我也一直在努力更注意这一点。当我真的决定就某个话题发声时，通常是因为我已经深思熟虑过，觉得这事值得说。
对。
话是这么说，但我也经常发现自己会往反方向想——我因为某人的技术工作关注了他，然后知道了他的政治立场，我常常会想，真希望我不知道这些。
所以，如果我对别人也这么想，那就挺虚伪的。
偶尔我也会参与一些有争议的讨论，那你就得接受这会有代价。我觉得你应该接受，而且更多人应该对此有所意识。再说一次，我们俩在这里也在自相矛盾，但说到底——
如果我们能更自由、更开放地谈论政治，纯粹从理智上交流想法，那该多好。但在社交媒体等当下的环境里，这可能吗？相当困难。不过，有些东西可能只是一时的——
也许我们能度过这个阶段。也许有办法回到巴克利和黑豹党对话那种状态，即使在社交媒体上也能做到，让那些讨论不再导致恶毒的群体围攻和取消文化。
对吧？其实我觉得我们现在比五年前更接近那个状态了。2020年时，部落主义和那些部落对异见者的制裁可比2025年严重多了。
至少在科技圈是这样。当然，如果你在学术界——你去哈佛的社会学系提一些右翼观点试试，我觉得不会有什么好结果，
而且你也不会很快从中恢复。但在科技圈和很多其他商业领域，至少现在你可以持有一种和2020年共识不符的观点了。这点是肯定的。
嗯，Rails社区有过一些风波，其他地方也有。后来怎么样了？都还好吗？
可以说每一轮风波都在缩小。就像我们和其他所有社区一样，在2020年前后经历了大型风波的感染高峰。然后你会看到——
每次新的爆发都比上次小。那些在意识形态上执着于这种斗争的人越来越少了。到现在，我认为对X来说最好的事情之一，
就是Blue Sky和Mastodon的出现。它们就像蜜罐一样，把当时X和推特上最恶毒的那批人吸引过去了，他们聚在一个不断缩小的回音室里，
经历一轮又一轮的纯洁性清洗，每次都缩小，到最后没剩多少人了。剩下的人现在也基本眼不见心不烦。这并不是说X是什么完美的地方，
或者那里偶尔没有处决式围攻。但确实少了。每次我被拉进Mastodon——或者没被拉进去只是远远围观——的讨论串，或者Blue Sky什么的，我都会想，天哪，这就是以前推特的样子。
而现在你真的可以像我一样待在X上，我90%的互动都是关于酷炫的Linux东西、酷炫的技术东西。看，我发现了一台新电脑，你看它多快？我可以和那些同样对电脑兴奋的人
进行这些对话。然后剩下大概10%的内容是，好吧，我会对某个有点争议的事情发表看法，我们可以稍微讨论一下，
然后就回去继续为电脑兴奋了。对。
算法其实非常擅长找到你会觉得有趣的东西——或者我不该说有趣，应该说吸引人。有时候是激怒人的，但它确实吸引你。所以显示出来的偏好是，大多数人想要的是推荐页，
他们不想要纯粹的关注流。
不，但他们就是沉迷于推荐页，对吧？
是的，没错。我——
我觉得如果有一个强大的LLM来做个性化信息流，效果会好得多。问题是如何在那么大的规模上实现，这极其困难。
问题就在于，奖励机制就是互动量，一旦奖励机制是互动量，互动就会顺着人的本能走，然后我们就完蛋了。不过我也不想太消极，对我来说，我
明白，我们每个人都有自己个性化的算法，有时候确实有点过火，但我觉得平均来看，过去这十年是X有史以来最好的时候。我这么说，是因为我是一个很关注技术讨论的人，很多
Linux的讨论，很多东西现在都能进行下去，不会动不动就被那些想把它拖进政治争论的人搅局
我觉得这真的很棒。其实我觉得X是个找这类内容的好地方。当然，它也能找到别的东西，我们都有自己的算法，但你没法对X是什么或不是什么做出任何断言。你的信息流大概跟我的完全不同，跟别人的也完全不同，对吧？
对吧，你的信息流大概跟我的完全不一样，跟别人的也完全不一样，对吧？
是啊，我没法评论这个，因为我要采访各种各样的人，我的信息流大概就是
这对你的信息流是好事还是坏事？是坏事，因为我可能就说一句“我在吃这个苹果，
真好吃。”然后一堆人就冒出来了。哦，因为你是泽连斯基的走狗，或者你是普京的走狗，你这
就是这样，好吧，
我只是偶尔会碰到一点这种情况，你就会想，“等等，什么？我们在聊什么？你为什么要这样冒出来？”这也是我其实很喜欢播客的原因之一，因为我发现
即使是在长篇写作里，当我做长篇论述时，人们也会用他们脑子里预设的我的声音来听。而这种预设往往在论点之前就定好了，就像，这人就是个什么法西斯。
然后他们听到那些词、读到那些词的时候，当他们看到或听到我实际表达论点时的语气，他们可能并不同意那些论点。我的意思是，很多人
当然显然不同意。但这样就很难简单地否定或憎恨一个人了。
嗯。
至少这是我的发现，也是我得到的反馈，人们会说，我本来有个看法，后来在Lex的节目上听到你，听起来其实合理多了。
但更重要的是，我希望人们也能用这种方式对待别人，就是先假设对方是个好人。对。
然后，如果对方有个你不同意的观点，那他就是个有好观点的好人。你也许觉得他蠢，没关系。觉得他迷失了也行。但要把他当好人看。我觉得如果你
从一开始就这样想，有个能带来互动的东西就是去挑别人的刺，
对吧？
如果你接触别人时就是在找坏的地方，你总能在他们身上找到坏。总有些让人烦的地方。如果你这样看人，你学不到东西，而且你会
让心里装满仇恨。你不会——这就是一种糟糕的生活方式和与世界互动的方式。而这正是互联网在某种程度上鼓励的事情。所以，如果你能哪怕对待那些你非常不认同的人，也说一句，哦，我可能能从这个人身上学到点什么，那就好了。黑豹党的那个人，威廉·巴克利，你可能恨他。嗯
就是这样，哦，我可能能从这个人身上学到点什么。黑豹党的那个人，威廉·巴克利，你可能恨他。嗯
这就是一个缩影
有个叫Theo的人，不知道你关不关注，我们之间有点小过节，是因为我们
在一个项目里停用了TypeScript，
他不喜欢那个，对此有意见，还干了别的事。之后我觉得，真是个傻子。到现在我还觉得那是傻事一桩。但同时我也能想，这人真的迷AI，他在
试各种模型，我们还能一起聊聊这些兴奋点。所以，我昨天刚开始关注他。太棒了。
就像，你知道吗？
我不必事事都认同你。我甚至不必喜欢你做过的、说过的一些事。我还是可以关注你。所以，如果我能回关Theo，那我觉得世界和平有希望了。
对，他其实是个很好的例子。他特别有主见，也经常改主意。有时候挺毒舌，但我觉得他底下是个好人。不管怎样，你知道吗？我的信息流更有意思
当有些人在聊我关心的事时。而且，我不必事事都认同你，我就是不必。这个——我觉得挺好笑，你提到你妻子说过一句让你记到现在的话：所有那些科技
圈里痴迷极端长寿的男性，就像女性的厌食症一样，是焦虑和失控的一种生理表现。这话不知怎么就有点道理。
对很多人来说确实如此。我觉得那条推文真的火了，不知道你注意到没有，Brian Johnson也加入了那条帖子，我能看出Brian可能会把这话当成有点刺人的
而且我确实觉得，Jamie当时可能就是在想他，也包括其他人。这也是个例子，说明虽然我不认同Brian的使命，我记得口号是“不死”。
对。
其实，我确实想死。我不想永远这么活着。我觉得人类寿命大概90到100岁挺合适。我接受生命的有限性。我们不必在这一点上达成一致。事实上，Brian对我来说是个有趣得多的人
正因为我们在这点上不一致。而且Brian愿意真的把自己的皮肤和各种身体部件都押上，去追求那个使命。这真的很有意思。我可以有这种看法。这真的很有意思。
我很高兴Brian在追求他的热情，同时我也觉得我妻子的分析有道理：底下似乎确实有点——我不知道——某种恐惧。我昨天跟Jamie聊到这个，她说
或者把它比作一种感觉：有些人觉得自己没活够。而他们没活够的原因之一，也许就是现代社会现在是个监控国家。其实不是国家监控，而是彼此监控。
到处都是手机摄像头。每一个失态，甚至每一次好玩的爆发、每一次尴尬，都极可能被拍下来，然后传开，被人嘲笑。在这种条件下，人类的理性反应就是退缩，
就是确保你不像没人看那样跳舞，因为很可能有人在拍你，
让你在互联网上极度难堪。所以也许你干脆就不该跳舞。
因此，如果我们都退缩到几乎没在活的地步，我们就会紧紧抓住，想让它永远持续下去。
对。那么，
我是说，我确信这个论点不适用于所有情况。我甚至不知道它是否适用于Brian或这里的任何人，但我觉得这里面有点东西：
如果你觉得自己真正活过，你就会坦然想：我活够了，有终点不是什么要对抗的事。那么，有没有可能这一切都只是存在主义的事后合理化？
如果明天有一颗永生药，我们都会吃？对，有可能。那如果我们真吃了，社会会不会更糟？会。有没有可能人类寿命是这么长，是社会学原因，而不只是
生物学原因？有可能。所以[哼笑]我觉得这些都只是有趣的问题，我就是觉得她的分析确实点到了什么，后来也一直在讨论。我是说，我觉得那条推文大概已经是一年
前的了，但最近我们一直在聊这些——过度优化者。我在Modern Wisdom上看到Chris Williams有一段说：“是啊，好吧，也许我们确实有点过头了。”而触发点是《CEO日记》，
主持人在里面说了类似这样的话：“我喝了一杯葡萄酒，接下来三天全毁了。”
好。
对我来说，在他那种情况下，我相信那是真的。比如你很久没喝酒了，只喝一点点，我能理解那会有影响。但这里面也有某种东西，触发了很多人——包括我自己——一种本能的反应。
我当时的反应就是：天哪，我现在就该来一杯葡萄酒，虽然我平时不喝。
其实我觉得酒精这个问题是个很好的切入点，可以拿来放大看一看。
我们好像都戒酒了，酒精销量大幅下降。
尤其在年轻人当中。一方面，从纯健康指标来看，我们可以说：哇，这不是很好吗？
但我不太确定这真的那么好。酒精能提供的那种社交润滑作用，也许失去了就是失去了。我的意思是，我们正处在一场绝对的孤独、痛苦、抑郁的流行病之中，其中相当一部分很可能就是因为你跟别人的互动不够。
这还没说到婚配问题呢，对吧？人们越来越难找到伴侣，而这很大程度上转移到了各种交友软件上，那些软件带来了各种各样的负面结果和后果，对吧？
也许我们将来回头看——或者现在已经在回头看——会觉得：哎，你知道吗，也许偶尔喝个烂醉并不是世界上最糟糕的事。
不管醉不醉，也许每个周五周六出去时喝上几杯，正是帮助社会走到今天的一部分。也许人类实实在在地喝了大概一万三千年酒，是有社交目的的，而我们拆掉切斯特的篱笆，是要付出代价的。
对。说到这个，我也该提一下。我早年在中国农村旅行的时候，二十出头，确实抽过一点烟，但只是为了那趟旅行才抽上的。
二十出头那会儿，但只是为了那趟旅行才抽上的。
一种社交纽带，对吧？
我还喝了巨量的酒，虽然我现在基本不喝，但为了社交场合还是喝了。那是他们表达爱的方式。我还吃了一大堆碳水化合物，而我平时是低碳饮食，我只喜欢肉。所以就是因为……
那是他们表达爱的方式。其实在那个社会里是香烟，但在大多数社会里，酒是大家一起喝的东西。
它是一种纽带。它带来的好处，在很多情况下可能超过负面后果——不管你怎么衡量长期影响。这就是现代性的短视：我们把事情简化成——好吧，在这项长期研究里喝一杯酒意味着你某种心脏缺陷的风险增加了0.1%。是的，但如果你根本没活过，那又有什么意义？
当然，也很容易滑到另一个极端，说唯一的生活方式就是每个周末喝醉、大吃垃圾食品、一天抽四十根烟。不，不是这样的。没必要非此即彼。
这也是我停止戴Oura戒指的原因之一。我戴Oura睡眠戒指戴了很多年，四年。
有一天我就想，我不需要知道我昨晚睡得好不好。我知道这增加了……
我不想管它叫焦虑。我没多少焦虑，但它就是多了一层提醒。
提醒我昨晚没睡好。这到底起什么作用？我为什么需要所有这些数据？我为什么要把一切都优化到——就像那位CEO讲了那件小事之后——我就想……
我反而想要相反的。
我几乎不喝酒，大概一个月一杯葡萄酒。你知道吗，我应该开始——就周末，喝一杯，也许两杯。
对。而且，我从来不是那种会为饮食焦虑的人。这是我结婚的一大好处之一——这里我插一句，千万别管一个四十多岁的女人叫"一位了不起的女性"。
我妻子特别生气，不仅因为我去年在她生日那天上了节目——这已经够糟了——还因为我在节目里叫她"一位了不起的女性"，因为那听起来就像她叫南希，六十五岁，住在罗切斯特郊区。所以我就……
我本来想第五年装傻说，我不知道，我是丹麦人，我怎么会懂这些？但效果不太好。所以我还是改说，娶一个了不起的女人吧。如果你娶了一个了不起的女人，她不仅
会做饭，而且真心享受做饭。你知道吗？这里有一种非常传统的分工方式，在人类社会中稳定存续了几万年。也许这
也不是世界上最糟糕的主意。我也知道有很多男人喜欢做饭，也有很多女人不喜欢。但就刻板印象而言，这确实帮了我大忙。我觉得，如果我不是
经常吃得比较健康，我不可能对吃这件事那么放松。但总的意思就是，从那种优化游戏里跳出来，同时又不要走到反面。你也不必变成瘫在沙发上的胖子。你可以动起来。
对。然后我们聊的更大的点是，生命是有限的。这一点我同意你。
这其实是我在 Amachi 里做的一个功能。
所以记住你终将死去。
对。
记住死亡。
如果你在 Amachi 里下拉日历，点时钟打开它。第一个有趣的东西是我从网上拿来的。有个账号叫 years progress。它每天更新，显示
2026 年已经过去了 63%。不知道你见过没有。
它就是这样填满的。所以我把它做进了日历。现在它显示 2026 年已经过了 63%。但如果你双击它，
它会问你哪一年出生？
你预计能活多久？默认是 90。我输入了 1979。然后在“今年过了多少”那一行下面，会多出一行，显示
你的人生过了多少？我想我现在是 62%。
对。
我心想，如果你把鼠标悬停上去，它会显示 memento。
太美了。不少人觉得这很病态，但这就是它为什么是个彩蛋。它不是直接摆出来的，你得点几下才能到那儿。我喜欢这种提醒。我喜欢时间有限这个提醒，我
应该充分利用它。这也是有孩子的一种特权。你会真正意识到，那些老套的话都是真的。天哪，时间过得太快了。
我记得我现在 13 岁的孩子，一岁、两岁时的样子。感觉就像昨天。它之所以是老套的话，是因为这是共同的经历。老套的话是好的。它们提醒你，你是人类经历的一部分，
别人也走过你走的路。
我得问你，你提到那个了不起的女人，还很会做饭。
了不起。了不起。
这很重要，要记住。不是“很棒”，是“了不起”。
太棒了。你之前聊到过关于可颂的事，我在一条推文里看到了。所以，丹麦的可颂真的更好吃吗？
其实，丹麦的可颂并没有特别好。在我看来，唯一能找到还算凑合的可颂的地方，居然是7-Eleven，这让我觉得特别好笑，因为美国的7-Eleven是那种——
至少在芝加哥，你去那儿是买冰沙、同时尽量避免被人杀的地方。对。
但在丹麦，7-Eleven是非常高档、特别好的便利店，而他们恰好做的可颂还不错。嗯。
让我一直想不通的是，我在美国住了20年，却从来没吃过一个能比得上哥本哈根7-Eleven水平的可颂。这看起来——
——完全说不通。
不，我真的认真考虑过雇一个调查记者来把这事查个水落石出，因为我听过的理论五花八门。是水的问题。是黄油的问题。是手艺的问题。是这个、那个、还有别的什么原因。
我想，这些对我来说都对不上。如果是黄油的问题，你不能直接进口吗？我记得在这边的超市里见过丹麦黄油，那个Lurpak。所以，不可能是黄油的问题。那会是——
——手艺的问题吗？不，不可能是手艺。世界上最好的可颂师傅，有很多法国人和比利时人就住在美国。那到底是什么原因？然后我又听到第二种说法，就是：不不，你——
——只是没去对地方。我真的去过15家所谓“对的地方”，结果所有的可颂都——对。
所以在我离开这个世界之前，我一定要搞清楚，为什么美国就是做不出一个像样的可颂。而且我甚至不是在要求顶级的法国可颂、顶级的比利时可颂，那些是世界上最好的可颂。
我只是在问哥本哈根7-Eleven那种水平的可颂。这要求过分吗？
这太有意思了，真是个谜。呃，往大了说，你最喜欢的——这让我很好奇。你最喜欢的一餐是什么？比如如果给你一顿最后的晚餐，吃完就杀你，你选什么？
这完全取决于那是午餐还是晚餐。如果是午餐，那——
——就一餐。什么——我觉得如果你要被杀了，是午餐还是晚餐其实无所谓吧。
取决于你是在一天中的什么时候被杀。
哦，我明白了。
如果我——如果是下午处决，那我就只能算午餐。
好吧。如果算午餐的话，那是在路易斯安那，哥本哈根北边的那家博物馆。我两天前刚和杰米去过那儿，我们经常去。博物馆很美，但我们不是为博物馆去的，我们是为那里的食堂去的。
呃，两天前，我们常去。那博物馆很漂亮。我们不是冲着博物馆去的，我们是冲着食堂去的。这听起来本身就很疯狂，好像你要开车半小时去一个食堂。但它恰好——
——恰好是我这辈子吃过的最好的午餐。那里的主厨简直好得难以置信。而且不只是食物惊艳，对我这种系统思维的大脑来说更惊艳的是，任何时候——
我们在那儿的时候，我记得大概有200人在等餐，而我们的食物5分钟就上来了。他们的菜单很小，显然是大批量做的，而且好吃得难以置信。
就是博物馆里的一家食堂。
就是博物馆里的一家食堂，恰好有我吃过的最好的午餐。
我们说的是什么类型的食物？是什么样的午餐？
就像北欧菜一样。有意思的是，我看着菜单的时候就想，你知道吗？要是我小时候看到这菜单，我肯定会说我不在这儿吃。都是些水果、洋葱之类的东西，
各种健康食材。听着就恶心。可等你坐下来一吃，天使都唱歌了。但还不止如此，关键是那黄油。
是啊。
他们那儿的打发黄油。全世界最好吃的黄油。
我觉得那肯定跟十字架有关。
肯定有某种联系。但说真的，就算在巴黎，我也从没吃过像哥本哈根路易斯安那那家那么美味的打发黄油。真的，我愿意开三十分钟车
就为了去路易斯安那的自助餐厅吃面包配黄油。
那你是怎么发现的？就有一天你去了博物馆，然后
我想我们就去了博物馆
你尝了尝，我们吃了午饭，然后我们就想，
“这太奇怪了。这味道能跟我这辈子去过的最好吃的餐厅媲美。我去过NOMA好几次，尝过那里的各种东西，而这里完全不输。”
好。那晚饭呢？既然你提到了，有什么不一样的吗？你得琢磨一下？
嗯，我觉得哥本哈根有很多好选择，但其实我要选西班牙的一个地方。在马贝拉有个叫Puente Romano的地方。那是一家酒店，海滩边上有个海滩餐厅，有新鲜海鲜。
好吃得难以置信。我想想它叫什么名字，反正你查一下就知道了，Puente Romano的海滩海鲜餐厅太棒了。
美食有多少是取决于地方和你跟谁在一起，对吧？或者你第一次去时的体验。
我是说，氛围当然有帮助，但我觉得我的味蕾也很靠谱。就是好吃。就是真的很好吃。因为那个自助餐厅，很多人可能觉得，我不会把它评为什么天哪，这是我想坐上两个小时的地方，但食物就是太好吃了。这就是我在全国各地旅行时体会到的一点，不带偏见地去尝试。
想坐两个小时的地方
是啊
因为你可能，我猜你可能会惊讶。说不定我会找到你的十字架。好，我们聊了死亡，聊了食物，
安排好了临终的事。呃，
你觉得，呃，一千年后，人类的未来、人类文明会怎样？你觉得我们能撑到
一千年后吗？
是啊，
老兄。我连十二个月后都预测不了。
我知道。
一千。
你觉得我们有机会吗？
我，我选择押注乐观主义。我押注多行星物种。我押注埃隆能把火箭送上火星，我们能搞清楚怎么弯曲时空，发现虫洞或者别的什么。
一旦我们做到了，你觉得地球上所有人类会死一两次，然后在我们有了一个好的备份之后重新繁衍吗？
我是说，那其实是我最喜欢的《黑镜》剧集之一，就是他们被上传到某个八十年代海滨小镇的那一集。我当时就想，哇，这既是一个如此黑暗的时刻，又如此美丽，因为
大家共同意识到，八十年代其实还挺棒的。就像我对很多时刻都没有什么怀旧感，但我确实怀念八十年代。他们说，不管你身处什么时代，你十二岁或者十四五岁时听的音乐，大概就是那样，会一直留在你心里。你看，我在八十年代才十岁。所以那是我的童年早期，我对八十年代仍然有一种
难以言喻的深厚感情。所以，如果我要被上传到某个地方，
你会希望是八十年代。
你想选八十年代。
我选八十年代。
哇。我觉得我其实从来没听人这么说过。通常是七十年代或者九十年代。八十年代嘛……
我真的很不喜欢九十年代。我们能聊聊这个吗？不，
对我来说，那是虚无主义的巨大转折点。无论是音乐、流派、时尚，一切都从那种华丽、流行、乐观，甚至雅皮士什么的，转向了油渍摇滚和
涅槃乐队。虽然我是说，我喜欢那些音乐，但我不喜欢那种伦理。我不喜欢那种道德。我不喜欢它的任何底层逻辑。那里面就是有一种
失败主义。回过头来看，如果我要被重新插进矩阵里，那一定是八十年代。
那充满了乐观和乐趣。是的。
还有色彩。
是的。我记得我有过一条橙色裤子。
嗯。
上面有白色圆点。在八十年代，小孩穿那种衣服很正常。我今天从没见过那样的。嗯，甚至九十年代，一切也都变得像西雅图灰一样。
大倒退。
所以尼采，你知道，永恒轮回这个想法。如果你过土拨鼠之日，永远活着，你想待在穿橙色白点裤子的时代。
也许橙色裤子可以跳过，但我肯定选八十年代。
你说对了。好了，DJ。非常感谢你所做的一切。谢谢你激励我们所有人，为世界创造酷东西，嗯，谢谢你今天来聊。
随时。谢谢你，莱克斯，再次感谢你邀请我。
感谢收听本次与DHH的对话。如果想支持这个播客，请在简介里看看我们的赞助商，那里也能找到联系我、提问、反馈等链接。现在，让我
用拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生的一句话来结束：一旦你做出决定，整个宇宙都会合力帮你实现它。感谢收听，希望下次再见。